I first heard about Hillsdale on a talk
radio program and got interested in it
as a teenager I already knew there was
gonna be a great place but it exceeded
my expectations in so many ways I've got
to say that my time at Hillsdale those
four years were the best four years of
my life just an incredible experience I
went to Hillsdale and and I was eager to
get out into the world and change the
world dr. Arnn would freely note that I
was here to make a name for myself and
to be famous he reiterated time and
again that I need to study I need to
focus on on becoming a student I became
a serious student humble enough to
really admit that I don't know
everything that I have a lot more to
learn I'm a state representative for the
25th legislative district in Puyallup
Washington this is my sixth year in the
State House of Representatives it's been
a great experience getting to know the
community getting to know a variety of
issues you're constantly learning new
things one of the very very important
things that I learned at Hillsdale was
the importance of listening that's
critical for serving in public office
and we have to find ways to strengthen
our communities to leverage the
relationships that are found within our
communities that is going to take a lot
of hard work by a lot of smart people
much like those who are coming out of
Hillsdale who are willing to run for
public office willing to get involved in
their communities willing to volunteer
and spend the time and go to the
meetings and do all the other things
that take up a great deal of time but
that are very much worth it because
people gone before us and have done that
in ways they
allowed us to be here and free I want to
be a good dad want to do well for my
family I want to do well for my
community very honored when I was told
that I was getting this award and
knowing the caliber of some of the
others have gotten this award
particularly humbled by it I think more
than anything else it is a challenge to
me to keep striving it is a reminder to
me of the principles and values that
he'll still stands for and that I ought
to stand for in my life
Hillsdale is doing a unique thing in the
country to be associated with that is an
incredible honor and it is something
that I don't